ici tu m'aimes plus marqué parce que je
trouve que faure représente ça ça fait
une bonne mise en situation
pour un départ de visite donc de mise et
où on s'attend au début avoir plus d
artefacts qui leur a été faite mais ici
ça nous met vraiment complexe qui touche
ce fascinant donc moi rien faire quand
je dis village est clair que si je ne
connais pas dit ça c'est donc et ça
c'était le quotidien des soldats lui
manque peut-être un peu d'objets qu'on
élit le la la température la boule et
l'eau qui nous mangent cause nous mais
c'est pas mal sinon ça ressemble pas
naît oui
on va dire à sion par la gauche oui
des gagne elle
puis déclenche les planches
il ya des cartes pour le combo
une table fabriquer
des cartes postales quelques fois